i'm saying would look at you in a rather
embarrassed way say who saddam who
an upcoming program on c-span 2's book
tv
next on encore book notes ron chernow he
sat down with us in 1998 to discuss
titan the life of john d rockefeller
senior it's an hour
ron chernow author of titan the life of
john d rockefeller senior how would you
describe him
rockefeller was described by william
james as the most strongly bad and
strongly good human being he had ever
met i think that probably expresses it
as well as anyone has ever expressed it
he was a man of such profound and
baffling
contradictions a man who was
simultaneously
the most ferocious of the robber barons
and the most farsighted of the
philanthropists and these two
seemingly disparate human beings were
rolled up inside one body in one mind
and that was really my task as the
biographer to try to make sense of the
two halves of this hole
what relationship is john d rockefeller
senior did senator jay rockefeller of
west virginia great grandfather okay
john d senior was the father of john d
rockefeller jr whose sons were david
nelson at all and then john d
rockefeller iii who was the oldest
grandson of john d rockefeller is the
father of j rockefeller and what in our
society would not be here without the
rockefellers well i think the
significant thing about the rockefellers
is that they were great institution
builders the john d rockefeller not only
created standard oil which was the
largest business empire on earth but he
created the most extensive
philanthropic empire that includes what
is today the university of chicago
spelman college
rockefeller
university
university rockefeller foundation and i
think that he has cast such a long
shadow because he created these
permanent corporate forms both in the
business world in the philanthropic
world and i should say ryan that in
terms of the business empire although
the standard royal trust was broken up
by the supreme court in 1911
to give you some idea of the size of
that trust
when it was dismantled in 1911
the heirs include what are today exxon
mobil
amaco
chevron
conoco
arco
bp america
cheeseburger ponds and two dozen other
companies so i don't know that the
business world has ever seen an
agglomeration of wealth and power on the
scale of standard oil
this is the last picture you have in the
book
people are fascinated by rockefeller's
face you can see there how seamed and
lined and and leathery um it was and you
could also see in that photo that he was
a um
more thoughtful man than people realized
a more philosophic man this was one of
the real surprises for me doing the book
that he was the most mysterious and
reclusive of the the robber barons but i
found in going through his papers that
he had spent an enormous amount of time
analyzing what he was doing squaring his
behavior off in his bad behavior which
he of course didn't see his bad behavior
squaring it with his conscience and his
creator and elaborating
a theory of monopoly that enabled him to
do what he did
filled with a
messianic
and self-righteous sense of
certitude
there's a photo here with the former
governor of new york nelson rockefeller
who else is in that photo okay nelson is
holding his eldest son rodman in the
middle you have johnny rockefeller
senior to the left john d rockefeller jr
nelson was the first of the
grandchildren to
have a
son and nelson very much identified with
his grandfather he revered his
grandfather and so he felt that he was
very much the
standard bearer um in that generation of
the family um even though he was the the
second son he had a way of kind of
nudging his older brother out of the
limelight i incidentally nelson and jdr
senior were born
on the same day which nelson took as a
very important
sign of the fact that he was
destined to carry on the
family tradition how was rockefeller
senior john d rockefeller
when he died
he was nearly 98 and in fact in the
early 1900s he announced that he planned
to live to the age of 100. and one thing
about john d rockefeller when he set his
mind to doing something he had an
extraordinary ability to focus his mind
on goals and he almost always achieved
them so that he was nearly 98 when he
died so he very nearly made good on his
boast that he would live 200 and he
became something of a new age health
fanatic and he had all sorts of theories
in terms of how he could prolong his
life for instance this was the bane of
his luncheon companions but he used to
chew
food 10 times before swallowing and
guests who observed him closely said
that even when he had liquid in his
mouth he would swirl or sift it ten
times before swallowing and what it
meant was that people who were
absolutely thrilled
to be invited to the luncheon table of
the world's richest man found themselves
after 20 minutes finished with their own
food
and for the next hour watching john d
finish his well maybe there was
something to this masticating
of the of the food because he very
nearly lived to a hundred you know in
the one of the earlier books we did with
linda simon on william james who you
mentioned earlier in your remarks
he fashioned something that william
gladstone had done chewing food 32 times
every time he ate uh what is this
business of counting
the number of times you chew in that
time of the world
actually i think that there was kind of
an old wives tale at the time that the
more you masticated the food and soaked
it with saliva that the easier it would
be to digest bronkefeld when he was in
his early 50s after he had created this
global oil monopoly
had a kind of breakdown it was both a
physical and nervous breakdown of sorts
and he had terrible digestive problems
it's very very interesting because
the source of that breakdown when he was
in his early 50s was not as one might
imagine the stress and strain of
creating standard oil it was the strain
of his charitable commitments
particularly he was creating the
university of chicago at the time so he
began a diet of bread and crackers
in order to cure these digestive
problems
what happened was that there was a whole
very pernicious mythology for the rest
of his life
that he could only survive on mother's
milk i mean this was part of this
vampirish image of rockefeller that he
was such a ghoulish character that he
needed mother's milk in order to survive
rockefeller who had very
little concern for public opinion
really never bothered to disabuse the
public or the the press of the fact that
he ate normally
and he ate whatever he wanted but
throughout his life he ate very
sparingly which is one reason that
people remember him not as this rather
rangy young man who created standard oil
but this spindly wizard little guy
hopping around
on the golf course or mugging in front
of the uh the newsreel cameras he
finally weighed around 90 pounds by the
time he died
what got you interested in this subject
well actually random house asked me to
uh write about john d rockefeller after
i finished my book on the warburgs and i
must confess to my embarrassment i
thought it was an absolutely
ghastly idea because i had done these
family sagas
and i was very eager to do a pure
biography which i thought would be more
compact and cohesive
and i told my editor at random house and
got off that i thought that rockefeller
was the worst subject imaginable like
that he just seemed to me cold wooden
mechanical
ruthless a man without any interior life
that i could say
and
she suggested that i visit a place
called the rockefeller archive center
that was set up by the family which is
run by a team of independent archivists
and
it was a strange day that i spent there
because i was almost trying to wriggle
out of the the project and i told the
archive director that i really was not
interested
in rockefeller because he had no voice
he didn't seem to have an inner life and
i said to him i don't hear the music of
his mind so how can i write a biography
about him and with that
he produced an interview that had been
privately conducted with rockefeller
between 1917
and 1920 was part of what was supposed
to be an official biography that was
never finally published so suddenly here
was this man who had no voice
who was who was so reclusive and
secretive and i have a 1700 page
transcript where he's giving a
blow-by-blow account of every major
twist and turn of his career
and i suddenly at that point encountered
a personality that i hadn't encountered
in any
of the previous rockefeller biographies
rather than this cold mute
reserved figure here was someone who was
fiery
he was often funny he was amazingly
analytical
in fact he was quite brilliant now i
hasten to say
he was often sanctimonious i could see
that there was a lot of self-delusion
and rationalization
he evaded a lot of questions about the
most controversial aspects of his life
but i saw just how much time he had
privately invested
into analyzing what he had done and
having written for instance about jp
morgan who
at most could concentrate on something
for five minutes here was somebody who
had spent decades
analyzing what he was doing who had a
brilliant strategic sense of the of the
oil industry and i said to myself here
is the fiery titan whom i had suspected
must be lurking somewhere
inside rockefeller but whom i did not
know for a certainty
existed because i had never seen any
evidence of it
in the biographies that had been written
about him and the transcript you talked
about in the interview was william
english william english right from and
every morning before rockefeller golf
rockefeller was summoned who did the
exact same things at the exact same
times every day so right before they
went out on the golf course every day
inglis would interview rockefeller for a
half an hour to an hour rockefeller
would recline on a couch with his eyes
closed very often as english was reading
the question to him rockefeller appeared
to be dozing and then rockefeller would
suddenly snap his eyes open and give a
very precise answer the structure to
that interview must be unique in
american economic history if not history
as general because what inglis did
he took the writings of
rockefeller's two most famous muckraking
critics henry demaris lloyd and most
notably ida tarbell and actually read
paragraph by paragraph to rockefeller's
most scathing charges
against him so this was a fascinating
document having him actually
confront
his most severe
critics and it was an extraordinary
document as soon as i saw that i knew
that i wanted to write the book and i
knew that this was
a rare historical opportunity of taking
someone
who was seemingly so familiar to the
public
and saying to them he's completely
unfamiliar you really don't know what he
was like
at all because he didn't want to share
it with anybody
and
you go back to the
why did uh
we'll go back what i want you to do is
go back to the the tarbell uh articles
that she wrote was mcclure's magazine
the cruise magazine from 1902 to 1905.
because in your book you basically
suggest that those magazines the
articles led to the breakup of standard
oil or to the sherman any trust act they
had a powerful impact
the articles were coming out in uh in
serial form
which meant that each issue of mcclure's
had a larger circulation kept jumping
from issue to issue
also because it extended over such a
long period of time with each new
installment more rockefeller critics
more rockefeller haters would come out
of the woodwork you know so that the
circle
of sources kept growing with each issue
and by
an extraordinary historical coincidence
ida tarbell was publishing this series
just as the man in the white house teddy
roosevelt
was looking to single out a single
notorious trust for an anti-trust case
in order to make an example of it and it
was really idi tarbell who turned john d
rockefeller into the most hated man of
the in the country and really um brought
all of the evils of the stanley road
trust to public attention just at the
moment when teddy roosevelt was not only
looking for you know a big brutal rich
unrepentant trust but one that the
public felt strongly about we have a
picture from the book and i'd ask you
because you've got a lot of pictures in
here where this comes from but this is
ida tarble sure uh in your book how old
was she do you know when this picture
was taken yeah this picture she was she
would have been
about 40 years old she's sitting in the
offices of mcclure's magazine you could
see that she was not only a rather
attractive person but that she had
tremendous dignity you could actually
see the the self possession of the woman
there and it took tremendous courage to
take on standard oil in fact her father
who had been an independent oil man
crushed by uh standard oil warned her
that she would that her life would be in
danger if she took on standard oil the
strange thing was brian that you know
far from being crushed by standard oil
as she was researching it
this lady kept taking shots
at standard oil over three year period
and didn't take any fire in return
what rockefeller missed was really the
two major things were going on in
american life one was the power of the
press
because ida tarbell was able to take on
a subject much more complicated slice
open standard or dissect it give an
accurate chronology of it no
previous generation reporters had been
able to tackle such complicated issues
and rockefeller also did not realize
that with teddy roosevelt power was
migrating from the legislative to the
executive branch and that for the first
time
um the federal government felt that it
had the both the right and the power to
take on the largest corporations in the
in the country and so that there was a
very powerful dialectic at work between
teddy roosevelt and the muckraking
journalists like guyada tarbell and the
combination overwhelmed rockefeller who
felt that he didn't need to dignify the
series with any response and it was a
fatal mistake he did not hire that is
standard oil did not hire its first
publicist until 1906 a year after the
ida tarbell series
ended today a corporate executive in
similar situation would probably have a
team of 30 or 40 public relations people
working around the clock i did tarbell
name comes up all through the lincoln
books i mean she wrote a lincoln book
that's often quoted in all the books
we've done here who was she and how did
she get interested in standard oil and
john rockefeller
she grew up in in western pennsylvania
in the 1860s and 1870s at exactly the
moment when standard oil was taking over
first the refining industry then the
pipelines then the marketing
and so john d rockefeller in her
childhood was a legendary figure was
really a bogey man all of her neighbors
she felt had been ruined by
standard oil particularly her father
so that this was a a woman who had a
score to
settle with uh with standard oil she
went to work for mcclure's in the 1890s
as she said she did the um a
biographical series on lincoln that was
very good and one on napoleon that was
significant because when she came to do
the standard oil series which she
started working on in 1901 she was
already accustomed to a kind of great
man approach to history
which meant that although her series was
nominally entitled the history of the
standard oil company
standard oil in the series is synonymous
with john d rockefeller now
rockefeller's no question was the
mastermind so he was the right one to
focus on
but rockefeller
operated by consensus he had very very
powerful lieutenants like henry flagler
and john the archbold you know men who
were
quite tough and and corrupt who got off
really scot-free in the tarbell series
because having done lincoln and napoleon
she realized that it had a very powerful
psychological effect on readers to focus
on one figure and particularly when
you're dealing with this gigantic
amorphous cartel called standard oil it
makes the whole story so much more
compelling and dramatic to focus on one
man so that there's remarkably little
about rockefeller's
very powerful colleagues in the in the
series so that all of the public
animosity that was aroused by ida
tarbell was directed at one man and that
was john d rockefeller senior how long
did it take you to write this
it took about four or five years to to
do it which is longer than i had worked
on the the previous books you know in my
naivete since i was doing a biography my
previous books had been family sagas i
thought that this would be more compact
and quicker
what i quickly discovered is that when
you're writing about john d rockefeller
you don't feel like you're writing about
a human being you feel like you're
writing about a sovereign state i mean
had millions of documents to use
where do you live
i live in brooklyn heights
which is just across the uh east river
from the lower manhattan uh skyline
within view of the uh the morgan bank
which was the subject of my uh first
book and we live in a
historic brownstone from the
1840s which had actually been a rooming
house during the civil war has a long
and rich history and we occupy the um
upper duplex of the brownstone were you
able to interview any living
rockefellers i did i had a couple of
very nice conversations with um with
david rockefeller the the family was um
guarded but cordial was his relationship
to john d senior grandson in fact i'm
really an adored grandson and because
john d senior lived so long david nelson
lawrence and all the rest were had
graduated from college that had married
they had started in their business
careers
and what david rockefeller said to me
said gee there's so many things i wish
that i had asked
grandpa
i think what he didn't realize is that
grandpa studiously avoided certain
topics in fact when nelson was a senior
at dartmouth nelson wanted to do his
senior thesis on standard oil and
vindicate grandpa against his critics
he wrote his father john d rockefeller
jr saying i so admire grandfather you
think you could arrange for me to speak
to him now most grandfathers would leap
at the opportunity to tell war stories
about their business career
a few weeks later a letter comes back
from his father saying that grandfather
has no desire to talk about standard oil
and i make much of this in the book
because in most families there's a very
rich oral history whereas the
rockefeller family
is a family that's riddled by strange
silences and taboos and i speculate in
the book and i'm almost certain i'm
right about this
that john d rockefeller jr
stimulated this three-year interview
that william english did with his father
i think because william o english
reading aloud henry demaris lloyd
reading aloud ida tarbell was able to
ask his father
as john d senior all the questions that
john d jr
had never been able to ask because the
whole subject was too touching you could
see john d rockfield jr actually
monitoring and secretly reading the
transcripts from this interview because
when tribal was um exposing john d
rockefeller he didn't sit down
with his family and say let me give you
my version
of events that you know what happened or
what i want you to think
happened he just left this family in a
very uncomfortable silence where they
were supposed to believe
in father's integrity really is an
article of faith what is a trust
a trust actually a trust um
became synonymous with um monopoly and
is almost used as a shorthand for it uh
today
what happened during the era of john d
rockefeller senior was that a
corporation
that was located in one state was not
able to buy the stock and the
corporation
and the corporation located another
state so it was very difficult to
conduct an interstate business which is
why there was a standard oil of new york
and there was a standard oil of new
jersey etc etc
the way that standard oil was able to
operate nationally was that the
individual shareholders
would pass on their stock to a group of
trustees who would then return to them
trust certificates so the trust was a
way for them to circumvent
these legal restrictions on operating
interstate it was a way of consolidating
all the companies in an industry and
hence became synonymous with monopoly
itself which is why it's called the
sherman antitrust act we still the term
still survives in the term antitrust
so if we were to find john d rockefeller
senior at his worst moment
or
as defined by somebody like turbo
where was he
where was he located and what was he
doing that made everybody so mad
okay rockefeller was um
notorious from the time that he was a
young man i mean we have to remember
that the oil industry like the computer
industry today was created by
young men which is often the case with
new industries and after uh colonel
edwin drake struck oil and titusville
pennsylvania in 1859 there was a wild
rip-roaring gold rush atmosphere it
wasn't the kind of thing that you know
all settled people rushed off to western
pennsylvania it was all of these young
guys who had just been demobilized um
after the the civil war rockefeller
created standard oil in cleveland in
1870.
he quickly realized that the most
significant factor
um in the competitive rush to dominate
oil was going to be transportation
because basically one company's oil
product didn't differ that much from
another
and so rockefeller created a conspiracy
with the railroads called the south
improvement company that not only gave
preferential rates to standard oil but
at the same time gave punitive rates
to rockefeller's rivals
when news of this leaked out in western
pennsylvania rockefeller was was burned
in in effigy there were huge torchlight
parades in towns like titusville and oil
city in franklin and the other centers
of the uh of the oil region and there
was so much protest
that this conspiracy was disbanded what
happened though was that during that
time where the conspiracy still seemed
to be very much alive rockefeller took
over 22
of the 26
other refineries in
in cleveland because his competitors
felt that they could not possibly
compete with
standard oil which was in cahoots with
the railroad so it was a very
significant moment it was the first time
that his name appeared in the newspaper
but then even though he was
controversial in the oil industry um it
was many many years before the general
public realized that one of the 10
richest and most powerful men in the
united states was this john d
rockefeller who controlled the oil
refining industry he was a very very
um shadowy and secretive figure
at what age did he find himself with
lots of money
well by the late 1870s even before he
had reached age 40 he controlled
um
about 90 of all the oil refining in the
united states how old is he there
actually there he's in his 40s that's a
wonderful photo
and one of the reasons i reproduced it
in the book is that when you look in
those eyes
you see this very
keen enterprising determined spirit i
felt that i almost had to erase brian
the image of the old
man with the newsreel
cameras because this is someone who had
been i mean just physically tall and
powerful and uh
imposing not this um you know shrunken
little man and people where is this by
the way that was a studio portrait from
the uh 1880s so rockefeller would have
been in his uh 40s now you can see in
the photo that he's a lot taller than he
looks very tall you know it's
interesting he's standing there with the
top head and cane this was a self-made
man who had grown up in rustic areas of
upstate new york look at how dignified
and polished
he looks um there and you could also see
the tremendously
imposing presence you know people who
dealt with him in a business situation
talked about these eyes
these piercing eyes that would just
drill holes
um through you um and uh william james
said that he was the most suggestive
formidable personality that he had ever
met this was someone who was a very
imposing presence later on he he becomes
this sort of laughing geezer handing out
dimes and i write about that and he
became a rather colorful eccentric old
man and that's fun what's this i didn't
mean to rob but i want to draw on the
eyes you've got this on the photo this
photo on the cover how old was he here
he was in his 60s and i love that photo
because i think you see in the in the
eyes
what a shrewd
canny and rather enigmatic character he
uh he was you guys there's a wig on here
he has a rig on he had lost all of his
hair he suffered from something called
alopecia in 1901 he lost not only all
the hair on his head he lost all body
hair
and this was
a great tragedy in his life because then
ida tarbell came along a year later did
this series portraying him as a monster
and since he was hairless and suddenly
looked old and ghoulish his appearance
seemed to
ratify what she was saying in the series
so that the timing was particularly
unfortunate
for rockefeller
we've got some a lot of photos we want
to show the audience uh but before we do
that how hard was it to get these
well the rockefeller archive center
they're about three or four thousand
photos there the difficulty was that um
when he later in life learned to love
the camera we have hundreds and hundreds
of pictures to choose from
um during the earlier years where he was
um so
publicity shy i mean during his active
business career he never
granted interviews never allowed himself
to be photographed so for instance i
couldn't find a single photo of him when
he was in his 30s i had two or three
when he was in his uh 40s so in the
earlier part of the book we had to make
do with the photos that were
did you pick all these yourself yeah i
went through all the photos i pick them
i um arrange them i consider that part
of my
job as as the author because it's part
of the image of this man that i'm
projecting to the reader before i show
the photos are you is this a full-time
job for you writing these books yes it
is how long have you done it
i've been doing it now since um the end
of 1986
what were you doing before that
i had a long phase from the time that i
left school in 1973 i worked as a
freelance magazine and newspaper
writer
for about 10 years i worked for a think
tank called the 20th century fund for
about three and a half years and then i
started work on the house of morgan
where'd you go to school
i did a ba in english at yale college
and then i did an ma in english at
cambridge university in england now what
is it about writing that you like
for me writing it's it's it's a it's a
sensual
pleasure really i i think that um with
any
writer with his or her soul there's a
kind of almost sublimated sexuality
about it if i can use freudian
language there's nothing that gives me
greater
pleasure than actually stringing
words together and i think that i'm
actually i think this is true most
writers that
we're writing all the time not just when
we're sitting in front of the computer
screen or
the typewriter or whatever what's your
daily pattern
my daily pattern is really i'm really
kind of a dull boy i wake up i have
breakfast i exercise to music or
national public radio
um
pour a cup of coffee get get a jolt of
caffeine
flip on the word processor and usually
work until around
4 30. and if the phone doesn't ring i'm
in absolute heaven but it usually rings
many times during the day you get block
at all
now you know i've never suffered from
from writer's block it's it's really not
in in my lexicon uh because i figured
out early on my own trick
for getting out of it
which is as follows
i if i can't write something i suddenly
imagine myself
explaining it to a reasonably
intelligent friend if that doesn't work
i imagine
arguing the point with the passionate
adversary that usually gets the juices
flowing so i started pacing my office
and carrying on this
imaginary
debate with someone who my picture
is very hostile and skeptical about what
i'm saying and then the words with that
anger begin to flow
what does it say about both
john d rockefeller and henry flagler
that they paid
300 to substitutes so they didn't have
to fight in the civil war this is an
interesting story it wasn't unusual for
you know for well to do men john d was
well to do in his 20s it wasn't unusual
for people to pay a substitute jp morgan
did teddy roosevelt's father did i think
grover cleveland did there are a lot of
different uh cases rockefeller claimed i
think that he was right that he had you
know paid and outfitted
20 30 different people to um to fight
what's interesting is that given the
fact that you know he was so money med
he marries into a family called the
spelmans
who wonderful family they were not only
ardent temperance activists but they
were ardent abolitionists
who had been conductors on the
underground
railroad they'd had sojourner truth in
the house and then rockefeller goes on
to found spelman college to educate
freed
uh female slaves and so there's no
question that he felt deeply about
abolitionism it may well have been
that um he couldn't restrain these
money-making impulses but another
important thing that i explained in the
book is that when he was in his twenties
his father
who was a bigamist and had abandoned the
family that john d has to
single-handedly support
his brothers and sisters
and his mother
there you can see the parents on the
left william avery rockefeller
colorful raffish mount a bank or even in
john's childhood would disappear for
weeks or months at timeout on the road
selling snake oil um john john d's
cunning side the rascality clearly
comes from his father on the right his
mother elijah's very strict um very
pious and all the thrift um uh
discipline industry uh religiosity come
from the mother so here you have the
product
of these
crazily mismatched parents who then
produce quite logically a crazily
contradictory son
the father
you say had two different names two
different wives two different families
that's right around 1855 he abandons the
family he will reappear throughout their
lives
every year out of the bloom but he
marries a much younger woman who knows
him as dr william levingston
they're married for approximately 50
years brian only during the last two
years of that 50-year marriage
does margaret allen livingston learn
that for decades she has been married
to the father of the richest man in the
world i keep telling people if a
novelist had invented this people would
say it was too preposterous a plot twist
and get rid of it nobody will believe it
i was able to completely reconstruct
this whole implausible story in terms of
not only what happened to the father but
this second marriage but also what his
relationship was with john
we also have
the
i guess a sister and a brother here of
uh
john d
right here he's with his older with his
younger brother and sister he's on the
right he's on the right and then brother
william who became a standard executive
is on the um on the left what's
interesting about this photo um is that
the children
um look very very grim and uh ensomber
in a way that i think can't be
completely explained by the photographic
methods of the day when was this taken
um this was taken in uh it would have
been around
uh
1852 because john was on the right there
was 13
years old what's interesting is that
from the photos we can see that he had
this rather grim and somber childhood
but in later years when he reminisced it
was this golden idyllic time it's the
value of photographs because very often
people tend to sentimentalize or
idealize their their childhood and so
the the photographic record speaks often
with a kind of objectivity that the
subjects don't
who's this lady
this lady is laura celestia spellman at
the time that she married john d
rockefeller her nickname was seti this
was 1864 when they got married she was
about 25 years old she was a very bright
lively intelligent young woman kind of
blue stalking she was a school teacher
she went to college at a time when that
was extremely rare she believes strongly
in abolitionism and
and temperance
she then later on as the years went by
she became an almost suffocatingly pious
lady she loses a lot of this
intellectual vitality that you see early
on
and one thing that many people have
speculated and i tend to suspect that
it's true
is that as the drum beat of criticism
against standard oil grew louder that
she took refuge in the
church so that she becomes a kind of
unreal and otherworldly
person who talks in a very high-flown
religious
rhetoric and it's strange that john d
who is accused of being the greatest
corporate criminal of the age goes home
to this household that is
drenched in baptist piety and feels no
discontinuity whatsoever between what
he's doing at the office and the um home
atmosphere that he returns to what would
you say that uh did well let me ask you
this way did he do anything illegal in
his life
he did a lot of the things that he did
um were certainly um unfair
uh i uncovered a lot of correspondence
where he was directly paying off
different politicians and at the time to
directly pay off a politician to kill a
piece of legislation was
illegal sometimes they used different
subterfuges and would hire somebody as
as legal
counsel what's interesting is that
rockefeller often pointed out that um
his most of his business career was
played out before the interstate
commerce commission was created in 1887
outlawing railroad rebates and before
the sherman act was passed in 18
90 outlawing combinations and restraint
of trade but what you see with standard
oil is that even when those two landmark
pieces of legislation are enacted the
behavior of the trust really doesn't
doesn't change at all and you can see in
the papers they're just trying to figure
out different
ways to circumvent the um the laws that
basically
john dean his colleagues regarded
government regulators as
nuisances to be
bypassed wherever possible
you say that he gave 250 000 in 1896 to
the william mckinley campaign for
president right how much money would
that be today oh that would be several
million dollars uh today he didn't like
politicians he felt that politicians
were basically
parasites who would shake down
businessmen i mean all of this bribery
he saw as extortion that is the
politicians shaking him down rather than
his paying off the the politicians uh so
that he had very little interest in
conventional politics i think that he
regarded these payments as a
really as a business expense he was
never somebody aside from writing a
check who would ever get involved in a
political
campaign you know it's interesting i
think brian that if you look at the late
19th century the people who were really
building up the country were the the
businessmen and not the the politicians
you know if someone were to ask you
whether you would rather read a
biography of john d rockfell or andrew
carnegie let's say
rather than rutherford b hayes or
benjamin harrison or you know which two
were more important i think we would all
say
rockefeller and carnegie rather than
harrison and hayes so you go through a
period in the late 19th century that is
one of tremendous political squalor
partly caused by the business interests
themselves so it was also not an
atmosphere that was likely to generate a
tremendous amount of respect in the um
in the business community to the extent
that the business community was not
directly responsible for a lot of the
squalor i remember tripping across the
grave one day when it was at the james
garfield grave in cleveland and he's
right across the street there from him
what's he doing being buried
in cleveland when most of the other
families in new york
well it's interesting you know it's
interesting that a lot of people in
cleveland are not aware that john d
moved there as a teenager started in
business as a teenage clerk in cleveland
in the 1850s started standard oil there
in 1870 and um not only
even after he moved to new york in the
early 1880s retained an estate in
cleveland until the um late uh 1900s i'm
sorry late 19
teens he transferred a lot of his
affection to new york he felt that he
was treated better by politicians in the
press in new york
cleveland really mishandled rockefeller
because today new york city has the
cloisters the museum modern art
riverside church rockville university
all of these rockefeller institutions
that might have gone to cleveland if he
felt that he had been treated better by
politicians and press in his own um
hometown
and so the family grave site um was in
in cleveland but certainly um his son
was johnny reichfield jr was born in
1874
and so when he's five or six years old
the family moves to new york so it's not
surprising that by that generation they
feel themselves
new yorkers but for john d
cleveland it was always like an
unrequited
love affair with this city
what did
he do about giving his money away
well you know the image of john d is
that he that he made a pile during his
career and then gave away a pile uh
afterwards if that had been the case you
know that's a cliche the businessman you
know who makes a bundle and then
sanitizes the fortune by giving it to
good works
what makes john d so much more
fascinating and enigmatic and compelling
a character is that he was
making money as fast as he could from
the time he was a teenager and giving it
away as fast as he could he was a
baptist he was tithing as a teenager by
the time he's in his early 40s right
he's creating spelman college in atlanta
then spelman seminary to educate
um emancipated female slaves by the time
he's in his early 50s he's
single-handedly
creating the university of chicago by
the time he's in his early 60s he's
single-handedly creating the rockefeller
institute for medical research today
rockefeller university first major
medical research institute in the united
states is creating general education
board largest educational foundation in
the country he's creating huge
philanthropic
institutions
throughout his career not publicizing
them and it's clear from his papers that
if anything he found it very distasteful
the idea of publicizing what he was
doing and frankly
for selfish reasons he didn't want to
publicize it because when there would be
in the newspaper an article about one of
his large requests he would receive on
average
50 000 letters soliciting money within a
30-day period after the appearance of
such articles his philanthropic advisor
frederick t gates said mr rockefeller
was stalked and hounded like a wild
animal everywhere he went everybody from
the most noble to the most ignoble
were
soliciting him for money how about his
children how did he deal with money with
the kids
well you know it's interesting he um
being a very puritanical sword he was
haunted by the corrupting influence of
wealth so that even though the children
grew up on these estates and certain
cases of several thousand
acres he had them on very strict
allowances one of the most interesting
details that i discovered during the
research was that john d rockefeller jr
who was the only son
the youngest of four children said that
until the age of eight he wore only
female clothes
in the interview this was a private
interview the interviewer said
to him oh you only wear female clothes
was that just because the style of the
time is that little boys you know wear
dresses he said oh no no you don't
understand we all wore hand-me-downs and
the three older siblings were all girls
and so the hand-me-downs that were
coming down to me were all you know
dresses and skirts this is how frugally
they were brought up so that john d
tried to recreate his own threadbare
childhood with the children even though
he was on route to becoming the richest
man in the world because he wanted them
to learn the value of dollar you know
and he looked at all these other
children
of the the grandees of the gilded age
and he saw them you know becoming
philanderers and alcoholics and
everything else and he was determined
that these children were going to be
thrifty and responsible and to a
remarkable extent he succeeded because
you see a lot of famous families burn
out after a generation or two the
rockefellers have managed to to go on
being a significant
force in business politics
and philanthropy in this country
what's the story of the widow bacchus
the widow back is this was a story that
was given currency by henry demaris
lloyd and ida tarbell the great
muckraking critics who claimed that back
in the late 1870s in cleveland that um
rockefeller had taken over a lubricant
plant owned by the widow bacchus and had
cheated her
when ida tarbell repeated this this was
a very trivial episode in the history of
standard oil which had a global oil
monopoly
but it had a very potent appeal to the
public imagination imagine mr
rockefeller
was so sadistic and so ruthless that he
was cheating
this poor widow
in fact he had offered her a very very
fair fair price and it was later
documented that in fact he had not
cheated her when the time came for
rockefeller to publish his own random
reminiscences in 1908 he devoted
probably more space to the widow-backer
story than any other because this
incident had had such a hold on the
popular
imagination that he himself said if i
crushed a poor defenseless widow then i
really must be a very terrible human
being and so he spent on what was really
an almost microscopic transaction in
standard oil history spent several pages
in his book defending his behavior it
was one of the few things that i did
tarbell
really got wrong it was amazing how much
she got
right but that one she did the
disservice
which one of the residents of
the rockefellers is this
this is john d senior's house called
kaiket he had four states this was on
his estate in the cantico hills of
westchester north of new york city and
that house is today open to the public
now it's about 40 or 50 rooms which
sounds fairly impressive but if one
thinks of the newport cottages of the
day and these these very you know
pretentious and rather elephantine uh
places this was a surprisingly modest
um place for the world's richest man to
to live and it shows that he was
generally an ostentatious person on the
other hand i should point out it was
surrounded by 3 500
acres and several
dozen miles of carriage trails that he
had personally
laid out so that the grounds are
beautiful but he was much more
interested in the in the grounds than
the interior of the the house he was he
was a very austere evangelical
uh christian and for him i think it was
rather pagan and idolatrous to have a
lot of expensive paintings in a big
fancy house and ballroom that was not
his dollar doll he did have a nine whole
golf course he had his own private golf
course at each of his houses that was
arguably his greatest indulgence
if you were to total up everything that
he was worth today what would that
figure be
okay
his net worth peaked in 1913 at um 900
million dollars
which if you translate into contemporary
dollars is 13 billion which does not
sound like very much but doesn't begin
to tell the whole story for a number of
reasons
he had 900 million dollars in 1913 the
entire federal budget in 1913 was 715
billion dollars so he could have
personally
paid for every federal employee in
expense and had money left to spare them
the total accumulated national debt that
year was 1.2 billion so he could have
retired three quarters of the total
national debt rockefeller made the
statement in 1917 he had given away so
much money he said that if he had kept
the money
by 1917 he would have been worth 3
billion which would be more than 30
billion
today
and would put him in second place behind
bill gates but bill gates's wealth only
represents one half of one percent of
the gross national product rockefeller's
wealth represented two and a half
percent of the gross national product
which is why um people claim with some
justice that john d rockefeller was the
richest man in american history
his grandson winthrop went on to be
governor of arkansas his grandson am is
a grandson
nelson went on to be governor of new
york and vice president united states
his great grandson went on to be a
united states senator you said he didn't
like politicians uh would any of those
men been in those positions if they
didn't have his money
i don't know it's a fair question but
one of the interesting things is how the
rockefeller attitude towards politics
changes because when the federal
government brings the big anti-trust
suit against standard at the time teddy
roosevelt rockefeller has a very very
defiant and rather contemptuous attitude
toward government
his son john d rockefeller jr is very
much inspired i think by the atmosphere
of woodrow wilson is interested in
public private partnerships he he buys
up the grand tetons valley
and gives it to the federal government
for what is today you know arguably the
most glorious national park in the
united states did over acadia national
park up in maine and then you actually
have nelson running for office and
becoming governor of arkansas
winthrop becoming a governor of um i'm
sorry nelson became governor of new york
went through became governor of
arkansas
when nelson first entertained uh the
notion of becoming governor of new york
thomas e dewey said he couldn't be
elected dog catcher in new york the
rockefeller name was considered that
much of a liability so while the wealth
was enormously
advantageous the the name itself
was both a help
and a hindrance because the rockefeller
name historically had inspired a lot of
hostility
what if this book is new you mentioned
the english interview before what else
did you find that that hadn't been done
before
one of the things that i did is that all
sorts of things that happened at the
standard oil which john d rockefeller
claimed had never been
had never happened or if they had
happened that had been carried out by
overly zealous underlings i was able to
directly
connect him to all of these various
nefarious activities that went on at
standard oil
to his credit i was able to correct
connect him much more directly with all
of his great philanthropic enterprises
because a lot of people felt that he was
detached from them whereas in fact he
was very actively shaping and monitoring
them
i think perhaps the single most
important thing that i did in this book
was i took somebody
who was considered
inhuman
and turned him into a human being
he was a deeply flawed human being but i
think that i bring him at least i hope i
bring him to life on the on the page
because he had been seen
as almost a kind of malevolent
automaton
uh throughout his his life and he was a
very
if you read the earlier biographies um
he's almost missing from his own bog
he's so ghostly he's so elusive so i
have in addition to a lot of analysis
and information i introduced hundreds of
anecdotes in the book just to try to
bring him alive as a person because in
his time and people don't know this
in his day he was considered not only
the richest
american he was considered one of the
greatest and most original and most
eccentric personalities that the united
states had ever produced and that
fascinated me and i hope that i catch
that you have a picture here of uh him
sitting with a couple little girls
yeah those are great granddaughters he
loves um children you know one of the
reasons i have so many we have 105
photos in the book and one reason is
that um you see all the different
expressions all the different faces of
john d rockefeller people tend to see
him in a very one-dimensional fashion
um when in fact he was a very very
complicated man there are no two decades
of his
life where he consecutive decades where
he looks the same he's changed rogers
here yeah he was great friends with uh
with will rogers and will rogers came up
with a lot of funny lines he used to
golf together and will rogers one day uh
said to
uh taran cafella um after rockefeller um
beat him at golf or paul rogers said to
him gee
john i'm glad i lost you in golf the
last time i beat you the price of
gasoline went up a dime
which is not bad another time um
uh will rogers uh god uh
turn the tables on uh john d there's a
famous picture of will rogers giving
john d a dime rather than taking one and
rockefeller sort of sitting there with
this comical shocked expression on his
uh face he loved billy rogers rumor will
roger's humor very kind of dry
um midwestern sort of humor was exactly
rockefeller's own
human he used every day in the
newspapers avidly looked for will rogers
um jokes didn't smoke
didn't drink no didn't swear no
didn't go to the theater didn't go to
the um uh to the opera this was the last
puritan
um and on that though a little little
it seems out of context with everything
else that and here's the picture i
showed it earlier uh that uh when he was
running around in the countryside in the
car you like to uh
will you explain it this is very very
interesting rockefeller's wife who had
been a sort of professional invalid for
the last 10 or 20 years of her life
after she dies in 1915
john d lives another
22 years there's no evidence during all
the years that his wife was in invalid
that he ever cheated on her he seems to
have been a model
husband one of many contradictions of of
the man a model husband the second she
dies he never has shown interest in
women
uh he's suddenly surrounded by uh women
oh yeah there's uh his his wife in a in
a wheelchair uh she was confined to a
wheelchair during the last few years of
her life as soon as she dies
um he develops a real roving eye and he
um
has this afternoon ritual where he goes
out with a party of people in this large
touring car
he always sits tightly wedged between
two bucks and women on either side
he has a blanket that he draws over
their laps and up to their necks and
his hot itchy fingers would stray under
the the blanket and so
rockefeller lived his adolescence in his
last years whereas when he's a young man
he looks very old and serious when he's
an old man he looks rather jaundy and
and young so he seems to keep getting
younger and even slightly silly as he
gets older how did you learn that the
last little the tail actually there was
a rather gossipy memoir that was um
written by his
uh chief gardener because when they
would go out on these afternoon drives
the gardener would often be driving the
second car
and he said one day they pulled up at a
uh stop sign
and uh this young woman who was sitting
next to rockefeller leapt out of the the
back seat and came running back to his
car and she's got in the
car and she said that old rooster
i'll never sit next to him again and
apparently rockefeller had been trying
to
to feel her up during the the ride one
last little connecting point here that
uh james thomas flexner's father who was
on this show is right here
right that's simon flexner he was the
first director of the rockefeller
institute for medical research today the
rockefeller university and when that was
started in 1901 it was a very very novel
concept rockefeller himself suggested it
it was novel because there was no
institute devoted purely to medical
research and at the time
the idea of paying scientists to sit
around and just daydream and come up
with discoveries was considered
something not only
brand new but rather
quixotic and even doomed to failure but
simon flexner very quickly developed a
treatment a serum for for meningitis and
it's been one of the great success
stories not only of the rockefeller
family but of american medicine
any plans for another book already for
you
i think the next one will have to be
shorter i'm a bit exhausted i've done uh
i've published three monsters
um in a ten year period plus one
the warburgs in the house of morgan are
still very much in in paperback and then
i did a short collection of essays last
year called the um the death of the
banker so i think the next project will
be something shorter and more in the
area of instant gratification what was
the most fun about doing this book
the most fun about doing it i think was
just penetrating all of his disguises
you know there are certain
biographical uh subjects who seem to
live for their biographers they record
all their thoughts and then there are
other maddening people who live in order
to torment and frustrate their
biographers and john d was the supreme
example of this type of secretive person
and i don't know that i penetrated all
of his disguises
for his
mysteries but
enough so that i felt that i really
created a fresh
portrait of the man where'd you get the
title
the title titan well you know there was
a dreiser novel called the titan i liked
the sort of novelistic
ring of it i also wanted a title
that would suggest business
suggest the gigantic scope
but would not tell you whether it was a
flattering or unflattering vision of the
man so i was looking for something that
was deliberately
um ambiguous and then also i like from a
design standpoint of a five letter title
i pictured it the way it was of these
sort of bold letters
um leaping off the page like that
and this is the cover of the book
titan the life of john d rockefeller
senior our guest has been ron chernow
thank you very much pleasure brian
titan the life of john d rockefeller is
published by vintage books an imprint of
random house visit at randomhouse.com
for more information next week encore
book notes with former south vietnamese
premier nguyen kalki discussing his
memoir buddha's child
for information about any